à 21h vraiment de cette affaire ce gros
dossier on va revenir sur une image
terrible d'un homejcking à Paris on va
voir si on vous passe l'image dans un
instant parce que on attend justement
vraiment voilà d'être sûr parce que
c'est une image effroyable des hommes se
sont fait passer pour des livreurs pour
accéder à un appartement ils ont
violemment agressé une femme qui se
trouve à l'intérieur de cet appartement
étranglement coup ils se sont mis à
plusieurs sur elle les caméras de
surveillant sont filmé la scène vous
allez voir ces images qui font froid
dans le dos
et on a égal
des images voilà de de ces
policiers d'autres individus donc qui
aurent été interpellés par la police qui
faisait des mêm même com similair
regardz juste les images des policiers
qui les interpellent et vous allez nous
en dire plus juste après parce que
exactement c'est pas la même affaire du
tout puisque les autres sont encore en
liberté regardez vous allez voir c'est
faites très
attention
euh alors vous allez voir ça ça Reda
c'est quoi cette cette vidéo non non
cette vidéo d'abord cette C
interpellation parce que les
téléspectateurs qui nous suivent ce soir
euh il ils vont on va parler de ces
images de cambriolur déguisé en faux
livreur qui sévissent actuellement alors
cette image là c'est une affaire qui
date d'hier oui euh vers 15h où vous
avez des les policiers de la bas du 16e
arrondissement qui ont été roqués par
une passante qui leur ont dit qu'il y
avait un individu coulé et en résumé les
les individus à la vue de là-bas qui
prennent la fuite avec un véhicule volé
les collègues partent en course
poursuite les individus cartonnent et
les collègues procèdent à
l'interpellation ensuite la la première
vidéo alors je vais la montrer la
première vidéo on a on a flouté au
maximum hein bien sûr pour qu'on voit
pasement elle tourne énormément sur les
réseaux actuellement ça vient d'arriver
et c'est vrai que voilà donc des faux
livreurs qui se sont introduits et et
qui ont été extrêmement violents vous
allez nous raconter Michel Marie faites
très très attention vous qui nous
regardez en direct même quand les
enfants commandent tout seul et cetera
faites très très attention puisque c'est
un fléo incroyable et c'est c'est il y a
plein de groupes comme ça qui le font et
c'est de plus en plus fréquent
regardez
c'est fait les repag et tout ces images
qui viennent d'arriver qui tournent sur
les
réseaux vraiment quand on voit ça
actuellement en France he c'est ça donc
des faux livreurs Michel Mar est-ce que
vous pouvez raconter à nos
téléspectateurs si s'est passé Reda vous
allez nous en dire un peu plus côté
alors ça c'est la la les images qu'on
vient de voir c'est la première affaire
d'une série de trois euh de TR vol à la
fausse qualité celle-ci se passe
r on va pas donner l'adresse s'il vous
plaît oui on va pas donner l'adresse
pour
les m on peut pas donons pas l'adresse
don que vous a dit que c'est en France
voilà
oui dans le
dansissement vol fausse qualité ils ont
les individus ont
sonné c'est une nourrice c'est une
babysitter qui a ouvert une Philippine
je crois elle gardait un petit un petit
bébé un petit enfant et dès qu'elle a
ouvert la porte persuadé que c'était une
livraison que c'était un coursier
euh les choses quif il s'est passé ce
qu'on ce qu'on ce qu'on vient de voir
pendant qu'elle était retenu par avec
une arme dans la bouche quand même un
pistolet dans la bouche elle a reçu des
coups elle a été vraiment brutalisé et
les deux autres ont fait le tour de la
de l'appartement pour voir ce qu'il y
avait de en joue en en numéraire en
chose à à dérober et ils sont ils sont
ensuite repartis et il y a eu une autre
affaire à Paris 8e cette fois-ci où
alors ils sont partis les premiers là
sont partis avec une BMW à priori volé
et on a exactement le même scénario à
Paris 8 mais plusut tôt le matin là on
est vers 15h de la milieu d'après-midi
et là Paris 8e c'est à 8h du matin même
scénario et euh ils se font passer pour
délivreurs ils sont trois et ils
prennent la fuite mais cette fois-ci à
bord d'une Peugeot on va vraiment pour
no téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent à
21h5 c'est une affaire très très
sérieuse et faites très très attention
Gill on va rappeler le procédé de ces
personnes qui se FT donc passés pour des
livreurs des livou Amazon et cetera oui
alors il y en a dans toute la France en
ce moment c'est exponentiel alors leur
stratégie est très bien rodée soit ils
sont au courant parce qu'ils ont eu des
fuites des tuyaux que la famille attend
une livraison et à peu à peu près au
même moment ils arrivaient donc là c'est
imparable votre collier est arrivé vous
ouvrez ils auraient des peut-être que
les les livreurs vra les livreurs
donnent des c'est une possibilité la
police enquête là-dessus ça c'est voilà
il y aurait des fuites d'information la
deuxième chose c'est que d'autres bandes
il y a une condamnation d'ailleurs
là-dessus repère sur par exemple un site
je je vais pas citer son nom des gens
qui vendent des choses ou qui achètent
des ch le boncoin d'accord il y a eu ça
il y a une condamnation ils attrapent
les gens des gens vendent sur le boncoin
donc ils savent que ces gens-là sont
actifs sur le boncoin et ils repèrent
l'adresse ils disent voilà on a quelque
chose pour vous et cetera et ils
arrivent chez la personne et même mode
opératoire ultra violence troisième mode
opératoire chez des commerçants là il y
a eu pareil une affaire des gens qui
arrivent chez une coiffeuse à domicile
tenez j'ai un carton pour vous voilà la
dame croit que c'est des fournitures et
dans ces cas-là il volle ce qu'il y a
dans
l'appartement de voir toutes ces scènes
que je vous écrit sont de l'ultra
viiolence il y a une condamnation à 12
ans de prison là dans les sones 12 ans
de prison c'est vous dire la viol dire
que là les personnes qui ont fait ça
sont encore en liberté nont pas été
appréhendé par les services de police
pour sur deux de ces trois affaires va
nous le confirmer mais ils sont en fuite
et il y a une affaire où donc la
première qu'on a montré il y a eu
interpellation voilà ils sont
expérimentés donc ils partent en voiture
volée très rapide et c'est très
difficile de les arrêter alors c'est un
DRAM donc faites très très on va en
parler avec Reda il va tout vous
expliquer également parce que là je vous
dis on est en direct et faites très très
attention même il y a des enfants qui
parfois commandent tout seul et ça on
sait pas voilà c'est et c'est vrai que
c'est de plus en plus courant Reda
quelle est la manière de faire de ces
personnes comme nous l'a dit Gill c'est
c'est c'est incroyable donc il y a des
groupes de plus en plus et eux ils sont
en liberté hein oui on on en a je vous
en avais parlé quand on m'avit invité
sur le plateau dans lors de l'affaire
guillaon on a un peu le même profil et
là c'est semblerait être des jeunes de
banlieu encore donc si vous interpellez
qui sont mineurs euh bah il y a une
atténuation au niveau des condamnations
donc les commanditaires sont aiment ce
genre de profil pour monter des équipes
ensuite ce qu'on peut constater quand
même par rapport à avant c'est que quand
euh vous aviez le ce qu'on appelait le
vol fausse qualité vous aviez un agent
EDF qui venait enfin un individu qui
enfin un un agent DF qui venait et qui
s'attaquait à des victimes particulières
qui avaient au-dessus de 70 ans et à ce
moment-là il y avait pas de violence
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'une époque
qui a changé écoutez bien il y avait pas
de violence et vous aviez un individu
qui arrivait dans le même temps euh en
costume qui prenait par exemple un bijou
qui traîne et qui disait à la dame voilà
madame regardez le monsieur là il vous a
volé le bijou et là il y a la relation
de confiance qui qui s'installe entre la
victime et puis l'auteur en costume et à
ce moment-là montré ses lingots d'or et
vous aviez des préjudices énormes parce
qu'on sait que les personnes âgées en
général es gardent beaucoup de de
fiduciaire ou ou d'or et là on
s'aperçoit comme nous notre syndical le
le le dénonce souvent que il y a une
montée de violence dans la société où là
maintenant vous avez des équipes qui se
montent et qui qui n'hésitent pas qui
qu'ils agissent on va dire de manière
assez sauvage et cette fois-ci il se
moque carrément des victimes comme vous
n le dites juste avant il y avait un
bébé qui était qui était sur place il y
avait une dame qui a fait preuve de
courage parce que si vous voyez bien les
images au moment où elle est molestée
derrière la porte elle enlève la clé de
la porte parce qu'elle sait je pense ça
c'est la déduction du policier elle sait
que c'est c'est filmé bien sûr et comme
j'en parlais dans l'affaire Guillon ça
ça peut être une piste pour les gens qui
enfin pas forcément aisés mais les gens
qui qui veulent mieux se protéger c'est
avoir une une une caméra Wii qui est
tout le monde peut s'approprier dans le
commerce avec cette détection euh des
visages ou ou pas des cette détection de
mouvement qui vous permet d'être alerté
tout de suite sur votre téléphone
portable quand quelqu'un s'introduit
chez vous les vol ils vont voler quoi
j'ai pas le c'est ça c'est ça c'est
passé ce matin on n pas le on n pas le
butin euh qu'est-ce qui on parle d'un
mais là dans dans ce cas de figure là
c'était elle avait commandé quelque
chose ou ils se sont introduits chez
elle par hasard ça c'est intéressant
d'après les les les premiers c'est c'est
difficile parce que l'enquête elle est
en cours c'est toujours c'est là c'est
on est du dans de ça va être traité
normalement en cours d'assise on en
parlera peut-être parce que je pense
qu'ils viennent pas par hasard c'est
c'est non ils viennent jamais par hasard
mais c'est sûrement une peut-être une
commande enfin je vais pas dire le nom
pardon une command ce qui fait peur à no
téléspectateurs et je vois beaucoup
beaucoup de de messages
ils disent on command la journée et on
sait qu'il y a un gang de gars qui font
passer pour des livreurs verou partout
dans toute la France et qui svent et qui
rentre chez les gens c'est extrêmement
voilà je vous dis ça fait vraiment
vraiment vraiment flipper Gill il y a a
quoi le propriétaire était dans une
affaire il se serait interposé avec un
marteau oui alors c'est l'histoire oui
dans la deuxième affaire qu'on a montré
c'est le conjoint qui si je puis dire a
SAU a sauvé sa femme parce que les
voleurs arrivent à entrer et il il
menace la femme qui ouvre avec une arme
de point et là c'est le conjoint qui va
réussir à intervenir qui s'interpose qui
tente de les repousser il il y parvient
il a un marteau je crois oui à ce
moment-là et donc oui oui c'est ça et
l'un des cambrioleurs à ce moment-là
l'attrape et il le pousse dans
l'escalier et l'homme le conjoint est
hospitalisé à Bicha avec une PL au crâne
il est poussé dans l'escalier mais il a
sauvé sa femme grâce à son hroisme oui
oui le marteau c'est dans la première
affaire qu'on fin par perd toutes
affaires dans la première affaire le
propriétaire donc le patron de cette
femme ah d'accord c'est ça voilà
exactement il était sur le chemin de de
pour rentrer chez lui et il est il est
informé de la situation il arrive chez
lui et lorsque les policiers de la BAC
prévenu également arrivent comme ils
sont en civil il voit trois types les
mecs de la BAC qui sont quelquefois d'
d'un look qui peut éventuellement
rappeler celui des voyou et du coup il
est persuadé que c'est c'est les voyou
qui reviennent il prend un marteau et il
essae de de de fracasser les les flics
de la bque non qui bien évidemment l'ont
interpellé l'ont plac en garde à vue et
il a expliqué ce que je viens de dire
c'estàd que il les il y a une confusion
et c'est pas c'est pas exactement c'est
C deux affaires différentes oui et je
voulais dire aussi par rapport aux
livraisons euh il y a un moyen aussi
d'éviter ce genre de chos c'est les
points relais relais euh mais bon oui
mais bon Michel oui
non exactement on aller pas chercher un
point rela ou il y a les points relais
et de plus en plus on nous propose de
déposer les les plis bah oui mais non
mais même pardon mais moi je suis maire
de famille même si j'ai rien commandé
que je voisun livreur peut-être que je
me dis qu'il s'est trompé de palier
peut-être que c'est pour ma voisine d'à
côté donc j'ouvre en en demandant oui et
voilàant c'est bien
d' voudrais juste vous citer un mot au
procès vous savez les livreurs qui ont
été condamné à 12 ans de prison au
procès l'avocate général a eu cette
phrase terrible il n'avait qu'un mode
opératoire la terreur ouais merci c'est
un truc de fou attention pense bien sûr
à la nounou et à cette famille qui doit
être traumatisé merci à tous tout de
suite les punaises de lit sur C
merci